[Music]
1987 breakfast killer is here
should never interfere the history
there's a bomb on the premises
[Music]
80 80s
DC's legends of tomorrow all new this
Thursday at 8/7 central on the CW hey
youtubers it's Charlie so we got Miami
Vice reverse-flash next week and I'm
also gonna be talking about episode 4
zombie episode blackest night dead space
Django Unchained Walking Dead episode so
you can see from the trailer they're
doing a mixture of plot based episodes
that are like Legion of Doom you know
like big Legion of Doom team-up
happening right here and more of like a
one-off adventures like the zombie
episode episode 4 so just to address
this really quick this is basically just
gonna be like a really fun Miami Vice
80s riff on a legion of Doom's story
because we're finally getting
reverse-flash and damian darhk-- working
together Malcolm Merlyn and Captain Cold
or the other two big members of the team
but the way the producers pitched it
even though they're all working together
to try and bend time to their will
they're not gonna be having funny
meetings where they all meet in that
Darth Vader helmet from the Legion of
Doom and the cartoons so you'll get more
stuff like this where the reverse-flash
and damian darhk-- are teaming up for an
episode so you might see another episode
where the reverse-flash works with
Captain cold or some other combination
of characters you also see Lance
Henriksen who is obsidian also in
costume later in the episode so we're
gonna learn a little bit more about the
Justice Society but this is in the 80s
like that's the time period there in the
last time we saw Justice Society was in
the 1940s so they'll have a little bit
of history to catch up on like what have
you been doing for the last 40 years so
that'll be a lot of fun and I'm a big
fan of Lance Henriksen so it'll be fun
to see him kick some ass as Obsidian but
for those of you asking where Captain
Cold is and where Malcolm Merlyn is
they'll make their appearance on the
show relatively soon Malcolm Merlyn is
bigger in the back half like he's just
been on set a whole bunch recently they
posted this Charlie's Angels picture
from behind the scenes so just expect
more of that so they're there 16
episodes two of legends of tomorrow not
23 like the other TV shows it just means
they'll be getting to the crazy stuff a
lot quicker but just address episode 4
so this was basically like a dead space
blackest night Walking Dead Django
Unchained mash up that's why the
stuff in space you know like the dead
space stuff looked like it was film like
an 80's horror flick in the stuff on the
ground like the zombie stuff on the
ground it was a little more Django
Unchained just because of the period it
was set in but it seems like they're
doing a better job of balancing the
character work with the action stuff
that was one of the problems of season 1
is there wasn't a whole lot of character
work so a lot of the big payoffs didn't
pay off quite as much so you have like
the crazy Confederate racists in this
episode that are like way over the top
but you have the bigger payoff at the
end when Jax is just like smiling
watching that house burned to the ground
but because that Wonder Woman trailer
just dropped the same day as this
episode dropped you might have spotted
the similar joke that they used like
Wonder Woman is trying to like fight
move around in that giant dress
vixen also kind of has that moment where
she's like how are we supposed to fight
in this crazy dress this is ridiculous
so I guess you could think of vixen is
kind of like the Wonder Woman of the
team Sara's a badass fighter but the
difference between Wonder Woman in other
female characters that are really big
badasses is that she also has super
powers in vixens the only female on the
team that has legit super powers but the
zombies so the way they explain it is
that it's basically just like a random
bioweapon that time pirates tried to
steal it's not like actual blackest
night Green Lantern and stuff but Never
Say Never if the Green Lantern's ever
did get referenced on a TV show it would
probably be legends of tomorrow just
because it is set in space and Green
Lantern's is a space based franchise but
overall episode 4 was great mostly for
the character work there wasn't a whole
bunch of comic book stuff happening like
the joke with heatwave starting to turn
into a zombie but then not being sure
because he already kind of acts like a
crazy person that seems like a zombie so
there was an actual Walking Dead shout
out like I mean they made a lot of
zombie jokes but Martin Stein actually
did reference the Walking Dead and then
you have like the big twist with Captain
colds gun at the end of the episode it's
a really nice moment I think it's the
birth of a beautiful friendship there's
all kinds of new pairings this season
like they're pairing characters off so
they can have scenes together so I feel
like there's a lot of potential with
heatwave Adam scenes I feel like that'll
be a lot of fun I'm really liking vixen
with all the characters I feel like she
has good chemistry with
everybody so no matter who you put her
in a scene with it will be a good scene
but just in general like if you weren't
sure there wasn't a lot in this episode
that tied to what was happening with the
Legion of Doom that's what's happening
next week so just remember it's kind of
like the x-files where you have a
mixture of mythology episodes and then
the one-off episodes but let me know
what you guys thought about the episode
you know like I said great character
work like you learned a lot about each
of the characters that didn't
necessarily have anything to do with
comic book stuff but next week it's
gonna be super crazy 80s style those are
my favorite types of episodes like when
they're really crazy within a certain
theme like as long as they don't stray
from that so hardcore Legion of Doom
Miami Vice ride or die it's gonna be
awesome
so that'll post next week and I'll say
congratulations to this week's DC
giveaway winner Eduardo Ruiz you win a
$20 Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
will be a new round that'll start the
next time I post a DC video but because
I postponed infamous Iron Man that video
will post next then I have Doctor
Strange Easter eggs and we obviously we
have Walking Dead Sunday night so
they'll also be some Game of Thrones in
there some way to so whole bunch of
awesome stuff happening this weekend
I'll post video updates on Twitter and
Facebook what you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to learn about
the flash reference inside the New
Avengers comic book and you can click
here for my Doctor Strange review thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight